hey guys today we're going to be looking
at which magic knight squad class 1a
would join
if they were part of the black clover
universe in black clover there are nine
magic knight brigades of various
prestige
and all of them operate under the
authority of the wizard king who is this
handsome guy right here
in order to become a knight you have to
undertake an entrance exam
and for a select few they are made an
offer to join one of the squads
these squads are ranked annually based
on the amount of stars that they receive
and a star is usually given for
completing dangerous missions or just
protecting the kingdom from powerful
threats
on this occasion i've selected 10
members of class 1a who would have
passed the exam
and will be looking at where they'd end
up if you're a fan of either series then
do be sure to comment your opinion below
and also like the video
as it will let me know if i should do
more of these in the future starting
with perhaps the most obvious selection
we have bakugou joining the crimson lion
kings now this squad is one of the best
of the best and for generations
they've never placed below second in the
annual rankings with one exception being
when they came fifth
which was actually their most recent
ranking for anyone looking to become the
wizard king which bakugou would
undoubtedly want to do
then the crimson lion kings are the
ideal choice it's common for members of
this brigade to be skilled with fire
magic
and this would play right in tobacco
strength as he could learn some
techniques from fighting alongside
feiglian and leopold and all the other
guys
also the temporary captain of this squad
was mara leona
and her personality is distinctively
similar to bakugou's
they're both fearless in battle and will
put their bodies on the line to win
regardless of the consequences also
they're both child prodigies and in
bakugo's case
he'd see the crimson lions as the ideal
squad to carve like the clearest path to
him becoming wizard king
so yeah he'd definitely be joining these
guys moving on to deku
it would come as no surprise to any of
you that he would definitely be joining
the black bulls
this is by far the most eccentric squad
with virtually
every member coming from strange or
unique circumstances for example you
have a royal who couldn't control her
magic
and a boy with literally no magic you
also have another guy who goes around
hunting other magic knights
and then you have one guy who drains
other people's magic so basically if
you're a weirdo this is the brigade that
you join
in deku's natural state he was
completely quirkless so in the universe
of black clover it's safe to assume
that he'd also be completely magicless
as well so whether he stays magicless or
maybe someone gives him magic power on
the day of the magic knights entrance
exam
i mean there's likely no magic captain
who's willing to take a chance on him
other than yami and regardless of that
this squad is probably the best for him
anyway
as there's a real sense of family and
they're all genuine friends
additionally in the most recent ranking
the black balls came second so
if deku joined this squad he would
outrank back ago at least for the time
being
following on from this we have aoyama
and i have no doubt in my mind that he
would join the coral peacocks
his flamboyant and quirky nature would
make him the perfect fit
as this squad is led by a witch who
consistently spends her days sleeping
and an equally flamboyant vice captain
who has cherry blossom magic and values
the beauty
of things above all else this brigade
ranked seventh in the latest rankings
and came in eighth place the year before
so definitely not one of the upper tier
squads and a brigade of this level would
be suited to aoyama because
while he's got talent i mean when you
look at class 1a he's certainly not the
one that you'd mark out as being the
most successful
for me the coral peacocks is the perfect
squad for him to join
but i actually think there's a chance
that during the exam the blue roses
might make him an offer despite him
being a man
for some reason i feel like he still
might fit in next up we have tenure
joining the silver eagles
and this one here is another no-brainer
so the silver eagles are one of the most
successful magic knight squads
and members of the silver royal family
are usually allowed to join the squad
without any kind of test
it's captained by nozelle who is a
pretty arrogant guy who looks down on
commoners
but crucially he takes his role of magic
knight captain
super seriously and has a high standard
when it comes to judging other people's
talents
despite loosening up since we first met
him tenure is still arguably the most
serious member of class 1a
when it comes to following the rules and
trying hard at school he also comes from
a famous hero family
which in the world of black clover could
be equated to coming from a royal family
tenu would join the silver eagles
because of every squad out there
they seem to be the ones most concerned
with doing things the right way
and having the highest standards so in
my opinion at least i feel like tenure
would be joining the silver eagles
the fifth student on this list is ochako
and she will be joining the blue rose
knights this team is all about female
empowerment
and basically just showing that they can
do all these amazing things without the
help of any men
and i'm not saying that this is
necessarily an ideology that ochako buys
into
but much like the captain of the blue
rose she's had a crush on a guy for the
longest time
and has yet to say anything about it to
him despite it being very obvious
to everyone else additionally she is a
strong and talented fighter just like
the members of this brigade
they ranked fourth in the latest
rankings and fifth in the rankings
before that
so again this is roughly the kind of
level we'd expect ochako to be at
i mean she's not really equal to the you
know the best students in class 1a
but arguably she's the best of the rest
okay so moving on to everyone's favorite
golden boy
we have shoto todoroki joining the
golden dawn which is widely regarded as
the best magic knight squad the golden
dawn is definitely the place to be
which was exemplified by both yuno and
langris who joined the brigade and were
able to rise the ranks quite quickly
shoto would fit in easily in this squad
as he outranks anyone in class 1a in
terms of natural raw talent
and he has the ambition to reach the top
which is arguably only surpassed by
bakugou and deku
the golden dawn will provide him the
quickest path to become the wizard king
which is exactly the reason why yuno
chose them despite having offers from
every magic knight squad
in the rankings that we're aware of the
golden dawn came out top on all
occasions
and their base is this pretty awesome
palace so yeah i think todoroki would
have an awesome time here
and there's no other squad that he'd
pick next up we have jiro
and she would join the squad that was
formerly known as the grey deer this
squad is currently led by ryl who is the
youngest squad captain of
any brigade and he's incredibly quirky
this brigade arguably has the best
collection of former members
with the current wizard king and two
squad captains all being former members
so basically if you're in this squad you
need to be super talented or have a
distinctive power like paint magic or
time magic or dark magic
and jira would likely have song magic or
maybe music magic if that's a thing
if she was in this universe and that is
exactly the type of unique attribute
that would catch the eye of real
during the entrance exam also during the
cultural festival
she showed us that she could be a leader
and help other people realize their
potential
and does that remind you of anyone
because it kind of does for me the next
logical step would be for denki to join
the green praying mantises
and i say that for a couple of reasons
firstly it's a squad entirely made of
commoners which denki would certainly be
if he was in this universe
and i feel like denki and sekei would
get along really well
i mean could you imagine these two out
on the town looking for dates
i can personally picture that very
easily also just thinking about it
kaminari would also do well in the black
balls because
while this quirk is quite powerful it
also has a big side effect that could be
seen as a defect
however because two other characters on
this list are in the black balls
i'm going to say that denki is staying
with the praying mantises seeing as i
kind of just mentioned it
the other student who would be joining
the black balls is mineta
i don't even really think i need to
explain this one like it's so clear i
mean he's a weird guy he's
he's surprisingly intelligent and his
power is quirky but very useful
in addition he works well in a team and
he values friendship also again he
constantly obsesses
over chasing girls or obsessing over
girls just like funeral so
i think those two would also get along
for the final character though
this is uh this is a harsh one i think
um but i have ogiro joining the purple
orcas
and to me the purple orcas are the worst
magic night squad period like
they've had several antagonists among
their former squad members
and in the past a few purple orcas
killed their own fellow squad mate
in a disgusting act of classism and
additionally their vice captain is a
pretty evil guy
and was easily defeated by a low ranking
member of the black bulls
and as if all of that wasn't enough
during the basket like kaiten they were
positively useless
and despite 50 of them putting up a
barrier it was destroyed by
one man and then a couple of purple
orcas were killed in the process
you might think it harshed me to put
ojoro in the squad as he's generally a
good guy who works well in a team
but his quirk kinda sucks and this was
the best fit that i could think of for
him
like i just can't picture him getting
into any other squad and with that those
were the magic night squads that class
1a students would join
if they were in the black clover
universe if you're a fan of either
series let me know where you think the
remaining students would end up
and be sure to like this video and share
it around if you liked it and for anyone
who's not seen it i would definitely
recommend doing so what else is
quarantined for
catch you guys next time and peace out